one boy two bills and a fry up what's
that got to do with Wes streeting title
of his new book tell me about the title
well the one boy is me the two bills are
my two grandfathers
um one uh on my mum's side of the family
in and out of prison throughout my mum's
childhood my childhood
um bank robber yeah he had a string of
convictions from robbery evidently not
very good at it which is why I was in
out of prison so very often and then on
my dad's side of the family a very
different Bill Bill streeting who was a
World War II Royal Navy veteran civil
engineer throughout his career
um and uh sort of pull yourself up by
your bootstraps sort of working class
story devout Christian so very very
different characters and then the fry up
is the
um the fry up that my mum had on the day
that she was supposed to have an
abortion my mum was very young she was
18 when she was pregnant with me my dad
was 17. and there was consensus across
the family that she shouldn't go through
with the with the termination so
um she did what she was she should not
supported so she'll go through with the
terminal oh sorry that she should go
through she was determined she shouldn't
go through with it so she did the very
thing that she was explicitly told not
to do which was to have breakfast so it
is literally the Fright that saved my
life amazing what was what was Christmas
like with your two grandfathers did they
ever get together no not particularly I
mean the the two families knew each
other and my mum and my dad have always
been in my life
um although the relationship did not
last uh unsurprisingly
um but no they're very different
characters and very different outlooks
very different sets of values obviously
um
although one thing I would say
um not by way of Defense but probably by
way of mitigation for
um my mum's dad the you know Bill
Crowley who was
as I say about prison yeah one of the
things that he revealed very much later
in his life was that when he was growing
up he was subjected to really awful
abuse at the hands of his father both
physical and sexual abuse
and when he revealed that I think so
much else made sense it explained why he
came into contact with Boston and the
approved school system very early on I
think his first offense was at the age
of eight
um and he maintained that relationship
with the criminal justice system
throughout his life and I think almost
became institutionalized by it and you
can
um understand why even the harsh
conditions of ball stall might feel like
a safer and more comfortable place than
home given what he was subjected to when
he was growing up I'm settling in Tell
me uh take me back to the East End
annual what happened to you
uh so yeah so I'm a lifelong eastender
so I've brought up in Stepney in East
London live with my mum for first half
of my childhood growing up on a council
estate in in Stepney
um I think it's
it's sort of fair to say that what we
experienced growing up was pretty tough
I mean my mum was when she did have work
it was low paid and insecure things like
Civil Service waitressing or
working behind bars and
I guess one of the iron is is that the
council flat that I was growing up in
wasn't a very nice place we experienced
um power outages when the electric meter
run out and the money had run out too we
had issues with things like cockroaches
and fleas occasionally
uh and yeah
um
the council flat that I wanted to escape
when I was growing up is now something
that kids growing up in my constituency
Aspire to because
um you know kids nowadays are being
pushed from temporary from Pillar To
Post and temporary accommodation and so
lots of the I guess lots of the
foundational security that I experienced
growing up although I wouldn't have
described it in those terms or
necessarily seen it in those terms at
the time the support network of the
extended family a great State education
that enabled me to go from where I grew
up to where I am today the social
security safety net
I think a lot of that has been eroded
actually in the last in the last 30
years why didn't you stay with your mum
throughout your childhood
well we got to a point where
um home life became quite disruptive one
of my mum's relationships broke down we
we moved quite a few times and
um you know at one point my mum was
actually moving into temporary
accommodation before getting another
Council flat and I went to live with my
dad to
um you know hit the home life with my
dad was much more secure much more
settled and I had to make that choice
really that
um
you know that's that's felt like a more
secure place more settled place to be
and so I made that choice at the age of
sort of 13 or 14 to live with my Dad
instead of my mum how difficult was that
decision
the decision was not very difficult at
all
um telling my mum was probably the
hardest conversation I've ever had in my
entire life
um and to be fair to her she couldn't
have made it easier because all she
wanted for me was what made me happy
um you know support my schooling in
particular
so you know in terms of
how she received the news she although
would have been very painful for her she
she couldn't have made it easier for me
if she tried
and how
how did you was it difficult for you to
talk to your parents about how you
wanted to live your life
well I mean I'm very lucky my parents
have always supported me always
encouraged me to aim high always
supported me in terms of my education
and aspirations the one thing that I did
find hard to show my parents you know
with whom I've always had a close
relationship a very open relationship
was when I was at University I finally
came out as gay and
although I told my friends at University
who again couldn't reacted better it was
the irony of going from a
you know very working class families
Cambridge University and people saying
you know you're going to fit in is this
going to be a a place for someone like
you it ironically was
the place where I'd felt most
comfortable to be myself and my friends
couldn't have made it easier but I was
anxious about my family reaction
um and was worried about I think the
thing that lots of young LGBT worry
about will my family react well if they
don't what would that mean for our
relationship what will it mean for home
life and that those one warranted fears
actually again you know my mum and Dad's
reaction was was great
um you know my my dad's only upset was I
hadn't told him and I think like lots of
parents they inevitably had all sorts of
questions and anxieties would my life be
harder would I be discriminated against
um but as I often say to to people you
know younger Generations now who are
going through the same thing and worried
about parents reactions you know it took
me years and years to accept myself and
to understand who I was I think you can
sometimes afford your parents a few days
or a few weeks if they're struggling to
come to terms with it a bit
um you mentioned Cambridge University
there
um
fantastic that you managed to get to
Cambridge what was life like at
Cambridge you said that you felt that
you'd fitted in yeah I love I absolutely
loved it and
um
I met people from backgrounds I'd never
met before I'd never met anyone who'd
gone to private school
um when I was growing up in my primary
school and secondary school they were
very diverse schools ethnically and
religiously but
with the exception of a handful of
middle class kids in both schools you
either poor or really poor
um you know in some ways they're sort of
the two strands of my family were
representing my classmates you know a
working working class family and and a
family that you know on the other side
that found it much harder and so rubbing
shoulders with people who'd gone to some
of the country's top private schools was
different
but one of the things I noticed very
quickly is that while they didn't have
material concerns in terms of their
finances income they certainly want
going back home from University and
working full-time in the way that I was
to play my way through
they they had lots of the same anxieties
that we all have about life whether
we're doing well enough whether we can
cope whether we're
you know feeling comfortable in our own
skins I think all lots of anxieties that
I think we all go through in life it
taught me a lot about
people from different backgrounds and I
mean I feel very passionate about
getting more working-class kids to
University
um to our Elite universities why why is
that the Holy Grail well it doesn't need
to be the Holy Grail no no no and it
doesn't need to be the Holy Grail no you
had Angela Rayner on your your sofa this
morning I mean we we come from very
similar backgrounds I think actually in
so many respects Angela had it even
harder than I did when she was growing
up but look at where she is today and
she's come through the University of
life she's worked her way up through the
Trade union movement and she is I hope
on course to be the country's next
Deputy Prime Minister what phenomenal
achievement I think there are things
that we can do to make life easier for
kids from mine and Angela's backgrounds
whether that's going to University
getting an apprenticeship I think lots
of the country's employers that would
consider themselves Elite and would
acknowledge sometimes they've been
elitist are now opening up more school
the roots and providing School lever
entry routes into kids from working
class backgrounds and opportunities to
earn and learn and work their way up the
business we need more of all of that but
there's no doubt in my mind that sort of
going to Cambridge and actually getting
involved in student Politics as well
which is often derided
so both of those things were engines for
social Mobility for me and have given me
opportunities that lots of people in my
my sort of background wouldn't have had
especially at that stage in my life
which aspects of your life so far uh
will contribute to you being a good
prime minister
well
I've hopefully I'll be the next Health
secretary
um and I think that well there's lots of
things actually one is
I genuinely think and I don't genuinely
don't mean this in an unkind way I
genuinely think that having more people
sat around the cabinet table who come
from normal or even humble backgrounds
will make a difference to our ability to
serve the interests of the whole country
and this is my fundamental criticism of
the conservative party in a way is that
it's not that I think they are
this stereotypical Village
when do you want to be prime minister
well I'm I want to be the country's next
house I want to be the country's next
health section this is such a tedious
round of questions so I'm not indulging
any more of this yeah okay you know as
I've always been honest about the fact
Charisma than the man that wants to be
the Prime Minister I I think that when
you look at where the labor party is
today
we wouldn't doubt any of us that the
state of the conservative party and the
implosion of the SNP have put wind in
labor sales but the only reason that lay
party has sales on the ship is because
of Care's leadership he took us from the
worst defeat since 1935 to being a
position where people not only think
labor could win the next general
election in some cases they expect labor
win the next general election now we're
not that complacent but he has gripped
the labor party he has changed the labor
party and put it on a course where we
could win the next general election and
I think he would be an outstanding prime
minister for the country I genuinely do
okay not just because of his
professional background on having run a
big public service but because of his
values what motivates him and because of
where he's come from in life he has not
he wasn't born with a silver spoon in
his mouth he's not had everything handed
to him on a plate he has worked for
everything that he has built you talk to
me about your health you had a terrible
health care I did a couple of years ago
I went through kidney cancer and it's
actually made me when Kira asked me to
be the Shadow Health secretary
I was absolutely thrilled
um
I I love the NHS I love what is given to
our country for 75 years I love the fact
that when I went through kidney cancer
the one thing I didn't have to worry
about was the bill
but there are lots of things that are
wrong with the NHS too I saw a bit of it
in terms of my own experience in terms
of some of the delays in getting scans
sorted some of the follow-up after my
operation
um wasn't particularly great and some of
my follow-up in fact none of my
follow-up scans have ever been on time
which I think is something lots of
people identify with if they're in
the backlogs which are now at record
levels doesn't help with the doctor
strike no it really doesn't that you
know the doctors Junior doctor strike
today the consultant strike next week on
top of more than 600 000 delayed and
canceled operations this is the disaster
for the National Health Service an
absolute disaster what I find
extraordinary and I'm the second labor
politician on your sofa this morning
we're a government ministers today
they're not in negotiations they're not
on the airwaves explaining what's going
on or apologizing or telling us what's
going to happen where are they it's a
total abdication of leadership and none
of this was inevitable by the way before
Christmas the nurses said the Royal
College of Nursing and Unison both said
we'll call a fast strike action if the
government simply sit down and talk to
us and the government refused so then
the nurses went out on strike once they
went out it was hard for the government
to get them back the junior doctors felt
completely unheard they went out on
strike and then extraordinarily
for the Consultants to go on strike I
just think this is a total vote of no
confidence in the government on the part
of the entire NHS Workforce and it is a
disaster for patients and I don't think
the NHS staff do want to be on strike I
think that they have been forced to this
position by a government that hasn't
listened and has consistently run down
the National Health Service over more
than a decade and yes of course this is
partly about their paying conditions as
the staff of the NHS but you talk to any
of them and they'll tell you this is
about patients too and in fact they slog
their guts out of work and get home at
the end of the day knowing their best
wasn't good enough through no fault of
their own one boy two bills and a fire
it's doing rather well in the best
seller chart I noticed it did it I was
really chuffed actually and the nicest
thing is people can write to me as well
because because they can my email
address is probably available for people
who've written to me saying how much to
identify with it that those are the
reviews that meant the most to me cover
the book for you there it's good to see
you thank you very much thank you for
taking the time to join us we really
appreciate it